-We're back with Colin Jost.
All jokes aside,
this is a really funny podcast
you do with Wanda Sykes,
and it's getting great reviews.
-Um, yes, I was very --
Anything that gets good reviews
that I'm involved in,
I'm surprised.
That's just my way
of thinking.
But people were
very excited about it.
Our friend Claire Friedman
wrote it and she's fantastic.
I was very excited
to do it with Wanda.
Wanda is in it.
Heidi Gardner is in it.
Cecily Strong, Neil Patrick
Harris, it's a great cast.
-You got Parnell.
-Parnell. That's right.
I'm definitely the worst one
by a large margin.
-That's not true.
But are you a little, um...
-I get suspicious.
-About the reviews?
-The reviews.
Do you ever see reviews
that they're so good
that you're like,
"This wasn't a human
that wrote this"?
-Like, here's one. "Hilarious.
The character development
is so specific
and the actors
are perfectly cast.
I've laughed out loud
so many times
and can picture all of it."
Five, five, five.
-Five, five, five. Hilarious.
Also, I think also this is
a little bit of a brag
about their own imagination.
[ Laughter ]
You know? They're like,
"I can picture all of it.
You might not be able to."
-Yeah.
You do feel like if there was
a second -- a fourth row
that said, like,
"my imagination,"
there'd be five stars there.
-It would be six.
"I imagine another star."
-Yeah. "Funniest thing
I've heard in a while.
Claire Friedman is a genius.
Colin Jost and Wanda Sykes
are incredible together.
Everything about
this is perfect.
It's like listening to
an amazing episode of '30 Rock.'
Cannot recommend enough"
is another one, all five.
-Genius. Claire Friedman,
a friend of mine.
Would I say genius? Um...
[ Laughter ]
"Colin Jost and Wanda Sykes
are incredible.
Enjoying it is perfect.
It's like listening
to an amazing episode," right.
And then I like that one person
found it helpful.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I will admit, that was me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was like,
"This is very helpful for me."
-This is the -- This again,
I would say with the words
still is positive.
-Yes. "Hilarious.
I listened to this
in one day at work."
Meanwhile, like, what's
the employer thinking right now?
That's like eight hours of work
that they spent listening to it
"and was literally
laughing out loud."
Overall, five stars
performance, five stars.
Story, two stars.
[ Laughter ]
So...
-Feels weird to be so positive
and then be like, "Story stunk."
-Yeah, story. But anyway,
really, check out the story.
[ Laughter ]
I know you're like, "I bet
the story is going to be good."
It will be. Don't listen to...
-I mean,
when you average it out,
it's still like, you know, with
those other two fives,
still comes out to like a four.
-Probably like high threes.
-Yeah.
-I'm no math guy.
[ Laughter ]
-We didn't get into this
because we're math guys.
-Is it called math guy?
-That was right before,
on that red carpet,
someone asked you
what's 12 divided by 3?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your mom had a birthday
or has one coming up?
-My mom's birthday
is on Sunday. I'm very excited.
-Very big fan of your mom.
-Doctor Kerry Kelly.
She was in the fire department
for a long time.
She's turning 21,
which is pretty exciting.
-But how --
You did not know her age.
-All growing up,
she would tell my brother
and I that she --
Every birthday, we would
be like, "How old are you?"
We don't ask now because
we don't want to know the truth.
But when we were young,
we would ask like,
"How old are you turning?"
And she would always say,
21 when we were kids.
-Yeah.
-She was like, "I'm 21."
And you know
I'm a fairly gullible person.
-Yeah.
-If you've ever seen me
on "Weekend Update" and perhaps
I've gotten tricked at times,
you may see me and say,
"That is -- I can't believe
how gullible this man is."
-Yep.
-So as a kid I was also that.
And so when she would
tell me and my brother
she was turning 21 every year,
I believed it for a very long
time, until I was like 12.
And one of my friends asked
how old my mom was
and I said, "She's turning 21."
[ Laughter ]
And they were like,
"Oh, no, what happened?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is she okay?
Is everything okay?"
And I was like, "Yeah, it's
fine. She's 21, I'm 12."
[ Laughter ]
And then they told their parents
and then my mom had to be like,
"I'm 45, you idiot."
[ Laughter ]
-You brought a photo of your son
Cosmo last time you were here.
-Yeah, he just turned --
He's two in a little bit,
a couple months.
-Gotcha.
-And he's a cute kid.
He's like -- He's doing
a lot of stuff.
He's like, very active.
-Do you mind if we show a pic?
-No, no, no.
That's okay. Yeah.
Please go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like he has
his dad's sense of fashion.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks.
Thanks for taking the time
to print that out to show that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was like,
"I know what'll be funny."
-We are gonna --
When a guest insists on
making an art card
and it goes that bad,
we do make them pay for it.
[ Laughter ]
It's not much.
-Yeah.
-It's not much, but we just...
-I was like, "I got it."
-I want to say --
I want to mention one member
of your family
who recently passed.
And I say this with all
sincerity, your grandmother.
-Yes.
-Who I adored.
And I remember the last time
I was lucky enough
to get to talk to her
was at your wedding.
And it was so exciting
that she was there.
She passed away.
Tell everybody how old.
-My grandma just passed away.
She was 106 years old.
[ Audience gasps ]
Yes.
So it's not even --
No sympathy at that point.
[ Laughter ]
You tell people like,
"Oh, my grandma died,"
and they're like,
"Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
How old was she?"
And you're like, "106."
And they're like,
"Oh, so kind of late."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She was turning -- She was 106.
And she survived COVID.
Like, she got through COVID.
And so I remember calling her
when COVID started and I
was like, "Grandma, are you
okay? Is everything okay?
And I swear to God, she was
like, "First the Spanish flu."
[ Laughter ]
"Now this."
And I was like,
"How old are you?!"
It's true.
It's literally the same years
as if it had been like, "First
the Titanic, now the submarine."
[ Laughter ]
-May she rest in peace.
She lived a long life.
We were lucky to have her.
-We were very lucky.
-I was very lucky to know her.
Thanks for being here, buddy.
It is just the best.
Have a great show.
-Thanks for having me.
-That's Colin Jost, everybody.
"Trust Fall" is on Audible now.
Audible.
Check out "SNL" this week
with host
Adam Driver and musical guest
Olivia Rodrigo on NBC
and Peacock.
We'll be right back with
Gael Garcia Bernal.